the Joe Rogan experience well that's the
thing you know what and I was in New
York all summer and all those all those
the up-and-coming rappers are like
trying to hand you a CD it's like what
am I gonna do with that they still have
CDs well then they do something then
they just click on this to scan this and
it goes to like a Vimeo page and then
I'm like cuz this guy in my phone now
like what just happened does he have my
contacts yeah so I just kind of steer
clear to them I can't weirded out by
those little queue scan things is that
what they call them was a cute queue
what was it QR code QR code I get
weirded out by those things because your
camera goes on it and then boom it opens
up a website I'm like what is happening
here I'll tell you what's a weird one is
they have home security systems now
where I was reading an ad for this on my
podcast and I was thinking like
afterwards like like a lot of times home
I guess I know alarm goes off cuz your
window blows open and then everybody
[ __ ] shows up and it's like oh sorry
the window blew open this actually has
video cameras so they can confirm that
somebody is in your house but then I'm
thinking like well what's to stop them
from just turn that on and start
watching your life like a show nothing
like a they're fighting again well for
sure if there's a stream it's possible
for someone to do that for sure if
there's a stream no no and the contract
it says we would never do that
oh okay oh it's not like some people
don't see the doorbell camera from ring
has partnered with 400 police forces
extending surveillance concerns yeah
yeah yeah I mean as long as they're just
using it to catch the bad guys which is
gonna be what they're saying but there's
gotta be somebody somebody has their
dick in their hand right now look at
through that doorbell it's an ID and the
way people get obsessed like and then
you're jerking off just to the woman
walking up to the door to go into her
house and it's not enough man I can see
what's up I got to see what's behind the
door
calls up hey would you be interested in
furthering your security no I think the
doorbells enough interesting you say
that we just had a case the other day
where unfortunately she thought it was
enough and it wasn't really and then
tells him that now he's watching her
eating corn flakes it's a slow creep
into your life how much time before it's
everywhere
before everyone can see everyone
everywhere yeah I don't know
well what's weird is younger people that
have a much different idea of privacy
yeah cuz they [ __ ] has kind of been out
there I would not want to be young right
now they have a real tough time where
dude when I was younger when I got my
ass kicked it was over it wasn't video
documentation for the rest of my life
this is the kid from Rocky Point he's
all grown up now and you're trying to
get laid in a bar like 20 years later
you're like yes that happened I was
always eight sorry I was just thinking
of that I watched this kid tried to
throw a triangle up in a street fight
and the guy slammed him on his head and
punched him unconscious and kept
punching him while he was out and the
kid just climbed off of him and walked
towards his friends and everybody's like
oh this guy's lying on the ground
pawing up his arms like probably
experiencing severe brain damage and I'm
thinking what if that was my son
you know what does your son you want
some some guys slam I'm on his head and
then as he's unconscious punched him
five six seven times in the face yeah
that's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] that's why I
stopped fighting that's why yeah I wanna
hurt anybody
no no I didn't want to be that guy I was
like baby fat tough until like [ __ ]
sixth grade and then I sort of leaned
out and I was like I better get funny
and then that's when people started to
learn how to fight and there was blood
and [ __ ] and I remember there was his
dude I think I talked to all this stuff
I got up the kid got off the bus he was
[ __ ] jack the other kid was kind of
baby Huey big guy but the other kid got
off the bus first he just jumped him and
then just sat on his chest and it was it
was like oh those [ __ ] fights the kid
didn't come to school for a week they
came back just by the time he came back
to school most of the somalian come down
but he almost looked like he was a
cousin it wasn't him yeah and I was just
like yeah I'm not
don't want that to happen to me so
that's one of the darkest things that
ever heard anybody say about a fight
khabib nurmagomedov said about Conor
McGregor he was I want to change his
face yeah see there's people out there
like that that are like yeah there's
this that okay I should stop now is
missing and you don't want to be
underneath all of that they just kept
getting worse the older I got that sound
of somebody's head hitting the floor the
worst and Sam WorldStarHipHop videos
where well the worst one I ever saw was
this guy was drunk and he was talking
[ __ ] and one guy knocked him out and
then when he's out called lying down
everybody took shots at him I mean
everybody in the street people were
kicking him in the hand were running up
to him kicking him like a soccer ball
punched him in the face I mean like 10
15 people doing it just running up to
him boom kicking him running up punching
him oh yes
horrific how did we get on this I don't
know I got a great special code yeah
your family's special it's nothing to do
with brain damage